this episode of legal eagle was made
possible by skill share learned to think
like a lawyer for free for two months by
clicking on a link in the description
usually claiming this is a
constitutional crisis in this
administration is just hyperbole but
something was different when the
administration attended to include a
citizenship question in the American
census the Supreme Court has already
answered that query with a big fat no
that 2020 census cannot include the
citizenship question on the census and
the government's lawyers told the lawyer
courts that they were prepared to comply
with the supreme court's order until
President Trump tweeted that actually as
leader of the US government he might
just use that question anyway and behold
we have what might be considered a
constitutional crisis on our hands can a
president defy or ignore supreme court
order has this ever happened before and
are we out of the woods when it comes to
a constitutional crisis that's what
we're gonna talk about today on this
real Law Review
[Music]
hey legal eagles it's time to think like
a lawyer since the day president Donald
Trump took the oath of office people
have been predicting a constitutional
crisis
the Constitution doesn't define anything
like a constitutional crisis it's
basically just a term that we come up
with when we have to suggest lots of
danger when it comes to the interplay
between different branches of the US
government but a constitutional crisis
over whether one branch of the u.s.
government would acknowledge the full
authority of another is a kind of a big
deal in its own right and that's pretty
much where we are today it appears that
we may be safe for the moment but it's
worth doing a full retrospective on the
census controversy because things keep
getting weirder and we're not out of the
woods yet so how did we get here first a
primer on the American census the census
requires the government to count the
population of the United States every 10
years counting the population includes
all people whether citizens or
non-citizens the census is mandated by
the Constitution in article 1 which
governs Congress's power the
Constitution requires the census every
10 years Congress delegates that power
to the executive branch but it is a
constitutionally mandated congressional
power the question of who to include in
a census goes back to the founding of
this country and the infamous
three-fifths compromise at the time the
southern states which had huge
populations of slaves wanted to count
those it when it came to congressional
representation while the northern states
felt that that was unfair because all of
these slaves were not considered US
citizens so for better or worse the
states reached the infamous three-fifths
compromise the census is used to
allocate federal funds draw legislative
districts and reapportioned
congressional seats although the census
once included a citizenship question the
Census Bureau dropped the question in
the 1950s because it caused an
undercount of the actual population
according to Census Bureau experts the
citizenship question scares people who
live in households that include
non-citizens census responses are
supposed to remain confidential and
cannot be given to any other federal
agencies to assist deportations
but many people simply don't know or
believe that their answers will be kept
confidential and including the question
can be particularly intimidating to
immigrants some studies have shown that
including the citizenship question
reduces the actual response rate among
households
least one non-citizen by as much as 8
percentage points and that is a pretty
big deal the ultimate goal of including
the citizenship question as explained by
Republican strategist Thomas hofler is
to allow Republicans to create heavily
gerrymandered maps we're likely
Democratic voters are stuffed into
geographically small urban districts
although Hoffler passed away his
correspondence indicated that he wanted
to use citizen population instead of
total population to draw legislative
districts which in his words quote would
be advantageous to Republicans and
non-hispanic whites and would dilute the
political power of Hispanics according
to the New York Times Hoffa wrote to
trump and other Republicans even before
the president was inaugurated urging the
Trump administration to include the
census question and obfuscate the reason
for including it claiming that it was
necessary to enforce the Voting Rights
Act once President Trump was inaugurated
he followed ha fleurs blueprint and
despite arguing in court that the
question was meant to enforce minority
voting rights in public Trump admitted
that that was not in fact correct the
real reason well president Trump stated
[Applause]
in other words you needed to do
precisely what Hoffler said to create an
undercount that would help republicans
and hurt democrats several states sued
the federal government after the Trump
administration announced it would use
the census to ask people if they were US
citizens as those cases wound their way
through the federal court system the
Trump administration didn't do a
particularly good job of coming up with
a facially neutral reason for including
the question and in fact although
Hoffler died a few years ago his
daughter discovered documents on his
hard drive that showed the citizenship
question was designed for the purpose of
giving white voters more power well it's
not a hundred percent clear it is
entirely possible that the Supreme Court
used that evidence to determine that the
Trump administration's reasoning for
including the question was in fact
pretextual so the Supreme Court said
that Trump and Labor Secretary Ross
could not put the question on the 2020
census and in fact I covered that case
in the roundup of Supreme Court cases
from this term linked below
now during the litigation the government
had repeatedly told the courts that they
needed to print census forms no later
than June 30th that rationale allowed
them to skip the intermediate appeals
court entirely and go straight to the
Supreme Court the Supreme Court's
decision happened shortly before that
deadline so when the supreme court
remanded the case back down to the lower
federal courts the Department of Justice
attorney is responsible for arguing the
government's position told the courts
that the cases were basically over and
that the government would print the
census by June 30th as scheduled without
question
now normally that would be the end of
this particular story at least until the
next census in 10 years but President
Trump had other ideas quote so important
for our country that the very simple and
basic are you a citizen of the United
States question be allowed to be asked
in the 2020 census Department of
Commerce and Department of Justice are
working very hard on this even on the
4th of July
DOJ lawyers were caught flat-footed by
this tweet and in fact Federal Court
Judge George hazel who is presiding over
one of the two census questions in the
US District for Marilyn said that he
followed Trump on Twitter and hauled all
of the lawyers both the plaintiffs and
the DOJ defense lawyers into his court
for an emergency conference with all of
the attorneys in the court conference
Judge hazel said that he follows
President Trump on Twitter and that the
tweet quote directly contradicted the
position that the DOJ had taken 48 hours
earlier the transcript of this
particular conference is pretty
remarkable even for a layperson I would
never want to be on the receiving end of
the vitriol the judge Hazel issued
towards the DOJ lawyers and believe me
contradicting something that you have
promised to a judge is definitely not a
position that any lawyer ever wants to
take but DOJ lawyer Joshua Gardner had
to tell the federal court judge the
tweet this morning was the first I'd
heard of the president's position on
this issue
in other words Gardner had no idea what
his boss was going to do or say with the
government's new position later that
same day the lawyers had the unenviable
task of telling judges in all of the
pending cases that all the stuff he had
said earlier about printing the forms on
July 30th and obeying the Supreme Court
well they were basically trying to take
that back so could President Trump
really defy an order from the Supreme
Court
well the framers the Constitution
believes strongly in checks and balances
building a system of governance where
the three branches of government
constantly had the ability to stop each
other from gaining too much power and in
the famous 1803 case Marbury vs. Madison
the Supreme Court established a legal
doctrine known as judicial review which
is the ability of the court to declare
legislative or executive acts in
violation of the Constitution now
judicial review was controversial at the
time since it's not explicitly found in
the Constitution however it has
basically been the law of the land ever
since 1803
at the time Alexander Hamilton wrote
that quote the courts were designed to
be an intermediate body between the
people and the legislature in order
among other things to keep the ladder
within the limits assigned to their
authority James Madison once said that
an independent judicial system provided
quote an impenetrable bulwark against
every assumption of power in the
legislative or executive and so as time
went on the Supreme Court got the final
say over whether a law was
constitutional or not there's actually
nothing that can force the president to
follow the orders of the Supreme Court
the court system doesn't have an army it
really doesn't have any police officers
except for a few marshals who basically
are just there for the protection of the
judges judicial review is one of the
strongest norms in the American
government but presidents have ignored
Supreme Court decisions before let's
start with a first real example of a
president defying the Supreme Court
Andrew Jackson and the Cherokees ever
since the Revolutionary War the United
States had openly desired to take
Cherokee and Creek land in what is now
the American South and Georgia had
claimed over a hundred million acres of
Cherokee land as its own the federal
government originally backed the tribes
and signed treaties guaranteeing that
they would never have to move treaties
that the government would finally break
when President Andrew Jackson came along
and signed the Indian Removal Act which
aimed to force Cherokees off of their
land the Cherokee government argued that
they had the same rights as any
sovereign nation and therefore passed a
law restricting white Europeans from
residing on Cherokee land the ensuing
court case wound up before the Supreme
Court which ruled for the Cherokee
Nation Chief Justice John Marshall wrote
that the Cherokee had sovereignty which
included the same rights of possession
as any other nation over its own land
the court reasoned that the tribe could
exclude people from buying its land or
residing there President Jackson however
had very different ideas President
Jackson supposedly said John Marshall
has made his decision now let him
enforce it Georgia decided to simply
ignore the supreme court's order and
President Jackson proceeded to let
Georgia do it wanted and that is how the
Cherokee ended up leaving Georgia for
Oklahoma on a journey that is known as
the Trail of Tears by refusing to do
anything to enforce the Supreme Court's
decision President Jackson was daring
the court to intervene knowing that the
courts enforcement mechanisms were shaky
at best and at times in the past the
court had ordered federal marshals to
enforce orders but there isn't really
any constitutional authority allowing
for this the u.s. marshals work for the
Attorney General the Attorney General is
part of the executive branch so the
Supreme Court couldn't send in the
marshals even if they wanted to in a
different case one of the biggest stains
on Abraham Lincoln's presidency was when
he suspended the writ of habeas corpus
during the Civil War a writ of habeas
corpus is a legal term that means that
every person in prison has a right to
petition the courts for his or her
release habeas corpus is actually a
right that is enumerated in the
Constitution but Lincoln suspended
habeas corpus rights early in the Civil
War preferring to hold prisoners
without any mechanism for their release
the Supreme Court held that what Lincoln
did was in fact unconstitutional but
President Lincoln ignored the order
because he was more worried about the
war itself and again there was nothing
that the supreme court could do because
his orders are not self-executing this
means that the court doesn't have any
ability to enforce its own orders in
reality the Supreme Court and other
federal courts have to depend on the
executive branch to enforce their orders
since the executive is responsible for
enforcing the laws and the vast majority
of presidents have viewed it as their
constitutional duty to obey supreme
court rulings and even enforce them when
the Supreme Court held that states could
not maintain an education system that
was separate but equal the governor of
Arkansas resisted racial integration but
at that time President Dwight Eisenhower
used his authority to call on the
military to enforce the Supreme Court's
integration order President Eisenhower
said whenever normal agencies prove
inadequate to the task it becomes
necessary for the executive branch of
the federal government to use its powers
and authority to uphold federal courts
the president's responsibility is
inescapable in accordance with that
responsibility I have today issued an
executive order directing the use of
troops under federal authority to aid in
the execution of federal law that Little
Rock Arkansas the National Guard went to
Little Rock to help make sure that the
Little Rock Nine as they were known were
allowed to go to school enforcing Brown
versus Board of Education most of the
time presidents will sharply criticized
Supreme Court decisions but they will
still follow the courts orders this was
the case in 2004 when the Supreme Court
struck down president george w bush's
plan to have prisoners held in
guantanamo bay tried by military
tribunals rather than the court system
similarly in 2010 President Obama
sharply criticized the Citizens United
case but still President Obama did not
decline to follow the opinion as laid
out by the Supreme Court nor did he
issue an executive order imposing a new
campaign finance system unilaterally
it's common for politicians to have an
opinion about whether cases are wrongly
decided or not but it is not normal in
modern times for presidents to ignore
supreme court orders which brings us to
current administration did the founders
leave us totally and completely unable
to defend ourselves against a president
who won't obey a court order well the
founders of America created three
co-equal branches of government and gave
the legislative branch the duty to
impeach a president who commits both
quote high crimes and misdemeanors now
defining high crimes and misdemeanors is
beyond the scope of this video but there
are plenty of constitutional scholars
who believe that it is Congress's duty
to impeach a president who refuses to
follow the law or refuses to follow
Supreme Court precedent now president
Trump tends to tweet about a lot of
things that make him angry and often
fails to follow through with some of the
things that he states via Twitter and as
possible that the census tweets from the
president are just another example of
saying one thing and doing another but
here President Trump first took to
Twitter to trash the Supreme Court's
ruling and then said he would consider
using an executive order to add the
census question by Fiat ignoring the
Supreme Court he said
president Trump follow up his comments
with tweets announcing that he would
make another announcement about the
census question during a right-wing
social media gathering at the White
House quote the White House will be
hosting a very big and very important
social media summit today what I have
become president without social media
yes probably at its conclusion we will
all go to the beautiful Rose Garden for
a news conference on the census and
citizenship however after days of
criticism during the news conference
President Trump back down with Ag bar
stating that the administration would
not be adding a census question after
all Attorney General bar offered his
interpretation of the Supreme Court's
decision and the legality of the
citizenship question and said that the
administration never considered adding
that question at all at the end of the
news conference attorney General bar
accused the media of being hysterical by
stating the Trump would use an executive
order to usurp the Supreme Court when
the administration had never ever
considered doing that some in the media
have been suggesting in the hysterical
mode of the day that the administration
has been planning to add the citizenship
question to the census by executive Fiat
without regard to contrary court orders
or what the Supreme Court might say this
has been based on rank speculation and
nothing more should be obvious there has
never been under conditions never been
under consideration I don't really know
how to square this statement with
reality
the president said exactly the opposite
of this and the news media was relying
on the tweets and actual verbal
statements that the president made
including a question and answer from a
reporter to President Trump the reporter
asked are you going to issue an
executive order on the census to which
President Trump replied we're thinking
about doing that it's one of the ways we
have four or five ways we can do it it's
one of the ways we're thinking about
doing it very seriously we're doing well
on the census so according to the
President himself of course the
citizenship question was under
consideration it's hard to criticize the
news media for being hysterical when
they're simply reporting what President
Trump himself said now what are the
consequences of Barr and Trump's
reversals is that the DOJ lawyers were
thrown under the bus in front of the
federal courts rad
then continue litigating this case all
of the DOJ lawyers asked to be withdrawn
from the case both in the Maryland case
and in the New York case which is
basically an unprecedented move it
really harkens back to the Saturday
night massacre under Nixon the
Department of Justice would not say why
those lawyers asked to be withdrawn from
the case but it's safe to say that some
of them refused to go back into court
and contradict their prior statements to
the judges and to potentially defy the
Supreme Court's precedent the two
federal judges who are overseeing the
various census cases were not amused by
this attempt to withdraw judge Fuhrman
of the US District Court for the
Southern District of New York would not
allow any of the lawyers to withdraw in
the middle of the case and stated that
the government's reasoning to withdraw
from the case were patently deficient
judge Fuhrman also said that the
government itself was responsible for
making the case a time-sensitive
emergency quote as this court observed
many months ago this case has been
litigated on the premise based in no
small part on defendants own insistence
that a speedy resolution of plaintiffs
claims is a matter of great private and
public importance this all goes back to
the government's insistence that the
case needed to be wrapped up by June
30th and that deadline had expired in
the end judge Fuhrman denied the motion
to withdraw for nine of the 11 lawyers
the two who were granted leave had
apparently quit the Department of
Justice prior to that decision Judge
hazel in the Maryland district federal
court followed suit by refusing to allow
the government lawyers to withdrawn
Judge hazel who's the one that conducted
the emergency court conference said that
his change in counsel did not give the
government a do-over and that even if it
added new lawyers the government would
still have to answer for the statements
it made before quote a change in counsel
does not create a clean slate for a
party to proceed as if prior
representations made to the court were
not in fact made a new DOJ team will
need to be prepared to address these and
other previous representations made by
the withdrawing attorneys at the
appropriate juncture for the time being
it looks like the administration is
indeed backing down and respecting the
Supreme Court decision however the house
has voted to hold attorney general Barr
and commerce secretary Wilbur Ross
in contempt of Congress for their
refusal to turn over key documents that
relate to the Trump administration's
attempt to add the citizenship question
to the 2020 census so this in fact may
just be the beginning of another
potential constitutional crisis and
dispute now it's unlikely that Attorney
General Barr fooled anyone about what
the president said or what the
administration was trying to do he
really could have benefited from subha
to hear Skillshare class writing
authentic fiction how to build a
believable character sabab walks you
through her personal process for
crafting authentic and believable
characters it's packed with exercises
prompts and tried and true techniques
that teach you how to create real and
nuanced characters that feel like they
could walk right off the page after
taking that Skillshare class you might
actually be able to convince people that
your character is telling the truth
Skillshare is an online learning
community that has over 30,000 classes
on everything like lifestyle design and
technology legal eagles will get to
three months of Skillshare when you
click on the link below plus it really
helps out this channel the free premium
membership gives you unlimited access to
must know topics so you can improve your
skills and learn new things all free for
two months so click on the link below to
get two free months of skill share and
start learning to think like a lawyer
today do you agree do you think the
citizenship question should be on the
census do you think the administration
will be able to come up with another
justification that passes muster leave
your objections in the comments and
check out my other real long reviews
over here where I will see you in court